on a voulu cependant le dinner
goss pas bougé bernard debré quelle est
votre première pensée quand vous
rencontrez une fille très très très joli
je te laisse la place maryvonne j'en ai
rencontré une je regrette simplement qui
est quelqu'un moi bien arriver à mettez
vous savez ce que je pense avoir changé
de la regarder
voilà c'est sale alerte ces alertes aux
roses maintenant je vous posais une
question que j'ai vu posé dernièrement
sur tf1 par un dénommé benjamin castaldi
qui avait demandé de baisser la lumière
d'ailleurs je félicite le couvrir de
cette émission qui volent très créatif
et pourtant aussi une question très
banal au fond quel est pour vous verrez
debré le lieu idéal pour une étreinte la
voiture ah bon non pas du tout non non
non les grandes déformations
j'y vais tous les racistes suisse il
faut donc d'un jamin questel dit une
note les questions parce que le mec qui
fait la même chose sur tf1
où êtes-vous incapable de faire l'amour
au bloc opératoire ou chinois bon
d'accord on devrait déjà atteindre
on a le droit d'être m mais une fois que
l'opération ait commencé ses comptes
mais c'est compliqué à faire mais ça
baise à l'hosto non ça doit baiser à
lost alors c'est pas du mensonge c'est
là où j'ai rencontré ma femme se tient
justement on y arrive a réfléchi
concentrez vous est ce que vous préférez
une femme qui baissent mal mais qui est
fidèle ou une femme qui baissent bien
mais qu'un fidèle à moi je préfère une
femme qui baissent bien et qu'ils soient
fidèles en même temps ce qui est
formidable c'est la mienne avec d'accord
bien sous préfet rey draguer ou faire
draguer à vous faire draguer sur les
titres merveilleux vous faire draguer
son vrai nom tu es plus un pack sans
quoi leur dire la vérité
est ce que vous préférez embrassez vous
faire embrasser à ça je vois pas la
différence
ouais c'est pareil
et jean claude brialy nous apprécier est
ce que vous préférez car ici vous faire
caresser alternativement préféré larguer
ou faire larguer olargues est fou ce
qu'une chose servait alors bernard debré
très important benjamin tu notes
est-ce que vous conservez un fantasme
non réalisés ah oui
haquin vous en occupez vous cherché à
rassurer
oui quand vous pensez que le jour où
vous allez mourir vous aurez réalisé
tout au fantasme
à ce moment là je réaliserai pas tous
mes fantasmes pour le réaliser ben non
parce que si je me dis une fois que j'ai
tout réaliser je vais mourir bajeux
réalisera pas tu en voilà